hey what's going on it's Bill Byrne it's
time for the Monday morning podcast on
Monday March 7 2016 what's going on how
are you how's your weekend
do you listen to the weekend I can't
feel my favorite hours you thought I
might use it Oh what are you doing Matt
you [ __ ] some chick on blow you
didn't do blow when you were with her
and I now you're with there now you're
doing blow the bush I can't believe that
[ __ ] came back you know I thought coke
was just done you know after all the
people did what they did for my
generation you would think that the next
generations would be like you know what
yeah I'm going to stay away from that
[ __ ] right it's not how it works one
generation does it like my generation we
were like wow man let's stay away from
hey man like let's stay away from LSD
and heroin because that's like a bad
trip man and then we [ __ ] with like
coke and crack crank all of that [ __ ]
right that ruined all of our [ __ ]
lives and then the next generation was
just like yeah man [ __ ] all that stuff
let's [ __ ] with crystal meth right so
now this next wave was like [ __ ] crystal
meth you know let's kick it old-school
let's go back to the coke right you have
an entire generation of people that not
only can't fill their faces but yeah
evidently they like it okay where do you
go from there sorry I'm trying to update
my my musical tastes I've decided that
after [ __ ] 40 years of listening to
the same [ __ ] tenth band you know not
40 like 39 Jesus Christ how many [ __ ]
times can you listen to it
I was like those you know those people
walking in the circle the circle in the
jail it Midnight Express remember them
when they walk in counterclockwise and
then the dude is going to escape but you
have the drugs you know whose girlfriend
put her titties up against the glass he
started walking around the other way
remember that
yeah that's what I'm doing right now I'm
walking around the other way and every
my generation is just going what are you
listening to this [ __ ] for that kind of
how many times he was dead I would
listen to that for [ __ ] 30 years I
gotta get I got I don't know I I just
yeah I would like to listen to something
new so the lovely Nia was watching the
all the performances from the Grammys
last night so I just started downloading
everything that I would see whether I
liked it or not I'm like I'm just going
to listen to this [ __ ] you know it's
kind of like when I try to put a new
hour of stand-up together I'm just like
at you know this doesn't this isn't a
good idea but I'm going to say it
anyways because I can't say the other
[ __ ] because that's coming out so I just
start throwing [ __ ] against the wall so
this morning I was listening to I
listened to a little bit of the weekend
dude sounds just like Michael Jackson
right I think he does and who else did I
download that girl looks like MC MC
serch right the [ __ ] her name I don't
know she was thinking about a
relationship and she was over it and she
just looked like she had this high cloud
fade you know but also knew what I like
make a [ __ ] rocket she looked really
smart you know yet like you wouldn't
want to [ __ ] with it I don't know she
kind of had it all going on it's like is
this a nerd it's just a bully
it's just a rapper or is she a witch but
the band is [ __ ] great so she I don't
you know after all of that [ __ ] I'm
probably not going to say who the [ __ ]
it is even if I figure it out because I
don't want to [ __ ] on people like that
anyways I had a killer SG though the
[ __ ] three pickups
you know excerpts and green they went
out they crushed it right
I actually saw what's-his-face there the
[ __ ] uh the dude who's getting the
worst tattoos ever
he's got the Lamborghini and [ __ ]
then like Ella no Keyshawn Johnson
chased them up his front door the [ __ ]
is his name Justin Bieber actually watch
that guy can sing he's [ __ ] talented
I just don't you should just just do
that just do that stop filming yourself
playing basketball and whatever else
that still would mean mugging
you [ __ ] GoPro just sing your song
and [ __ ] go home
well I wouldn't you do that it's
actually a talented kick although I
didn't like when he threw the acoustic
guitar down them again you know we
[ __ ] Pete Townsend you're not okay
key you get the inner ear [ __ ]
monitor you're protecting your hearing
okay you're not being on ty nobody's
blowing up a drumset and part of the
[ __ ] drum set goes right in your
[ __ ] Erica yeah nobody's getting
crushed your [ __ ] concerts they've
worked all of that out you know sorry
and then I go right back to the grumpy
old man I'm just I'm trying to give a
kid a copy [ __ ] really talented you
can actually really think so anyways and
now this is the other dude there what
the [ __ ] should be I for the life of me
I don't understand why I can't just
download [ __ ] and then just find it and
every [ __ ] time it goes back to the
album thing I like when they just list
the songs I don't need to see the
picture of the album every time this
happens I forget how to do it oh okay
artists songs there we go oh and
speaking of which on everybody was
sending a bunch each week when I do the
Thursday Thursday afternoon just before
Friday Monday morning podcast you know
when we go into the greatest hits of the
Monday morning podcast is always a
little musical interlude I do not pick
that music that's Andrew semblance and
then he posts on the Twitter site what
the name of the music is so last week it
was snarky puppy okay
that's who the [ __ ] it was he posted
every week just [ __ ] look it up right
at the mm podcast or some [ __ ] I forget
what I don't know what the Twitter
account
we'll follow myself anyways plowing
ahead so Friday night all rattle I took
a night off from stand up
alright Friday that's a big night to
take a night off that's like not showing
up Thanksgiving you know if you like to
eat you know so I went down to the
Wiltern theater and with Andrew and I
saw mute math and they were [ __ ]
unbelievable cannot I tweet it I
couldn't I cannot overstate how great a
[ __ ] show that was and I wish I
remember the name of the opening band
who they were all so great but what just
killed me was I had never been to a show
like that like whatever that style of
music is I don't even know what the
style of music is but just going from
you know the [ __ ] I've been listening to
but thirty years straight way okay she
walking in Baja diving in Kazakh I
listen to stay I listen to the same
ninety songs for thirty [ __ ] years in
a row
never wanted to be that guy so just
going to those seeing those bands just
how they use guitar where it's more used
for like mood where but when I was
growing up like the guitar was like the
dick that got thrown on the table right
just slap you right in the face with it
there was always the lead singer and
then you had the guitar god and then the
[ __ ] dude playing rhythm guitar who
was not appreciated until at least
twenty five years into that band's
career you know Mike Malcolm young
really didn't get his props until till
like the mid 90s I feel Brad Whitford
same [ __ ] thing you know Ronnie Wood
all of these guys just playing rhythm
guitar holding the whole [ __ ] thing
together right and they don't get [ __ ]
for the longest [ __ ] time but Jesus
Christ you mass live man this [ __ ]
unreal so by the way they're playing
Portland Oregon tonight
that's Monday depending on when you
listen this Tuesday they're in Seattle
then they're off for a week and then
they start back up again in Richmond if
you get a chance to see them you will
not be disappointed and if you're an old
[ __ ] like me they are a great
and to go see to try to bring you into
the modern era you know if you're
listening to this we come on you can't
tell me somebody's a little bit younger
than me you haven't been listen to this
[ __ ] Pearl Jam record 10yo weather
all giving each other the high five the
big bro picture we're all in this
together they're right you can't tell me
that you haven't listened to how many
times you know gibberish oh yeah [ __ ]
25 years later I'm not saying don't ever
listen to it again right look you could
do whatever the [ __ ] you want but I
never wanted to be that guy going at a
music right and going into my house back
I just look Betty Betty but Abba do boo
boo right going in there doing the
[ __ ] jitterbug having said that Jeff
Beck is playing the Hollywood Bowl and I
have to see that guy he's like 70 he's
bloody guy is opening up and there's no
[ __ ] way I'm going to miss that
you know guys want to Gracie he is the
guy you know I think from that whole
[ __ ] era other than Jimi Hendrix like
but yeah I think you got to give it to
Jeff Beck right now to my mind I'm sure
there's some black guy out there that
I'm forgetting you know who got stolen
from budgets as far as white dudes who
listen to black dudes and then reshaped
it right I think you got to give it to
that guy no well you know it's just my
opinion you don't got to get [ __ ]
upset by it so anyways what I'm obsessed
with right now as far as like the
drummer guarantee the guy's [ __ ]
insane and it was funny because you know
Andrew got to know those guys so I got
to go backstage and meet him briefly and
you know after the show they were go
ahead you learn anything watching our
drummer and I was just like no and I
heard the drum Geragos ah like I didn't
mean it I hope I didn't come off and
insult the great dude I get too [ __ ]
far beyond anything that I'm doing
watching him it was like watching like
Keith it was like Keith Moon playing
drum and bass
and then they have this kick-ass [ __ ]
light show going on and I was just
sitting it squinting watching just going
like why what is he doing
hey no [ __ ] clue I did take one video
while that while they were playing
because I it's coolest you know the
iPhone is and how great the video is and
everything I just [ __ ] hate like
being at something and then just sitting
there filming it like I'm working for
CBS Nightly News or some [ __ ] it's like
I want to stand here and I want to take
the tin there's enough other kunti r
like filming this [ __ ] I can watch this
it'll be on the internet forever right
so anyways this song clipping that they
play and I had no idea what he was doing
and Andrew was gone watch where he dug
him he literally has like two drumsticks
and two drumsticks in his right hand and
he's playing this is going to be some
drum geek [ __ ] so you might want to pass
through this he's play as far as I guess
I was basically playing sixteenth note
triplets that did that did that to the
ticket to the 3/4 right but he's only
he's playing like he's doing it with two
sticks in one hand so the one on tops at
the top of the I had the one underneath
he's hitting the bottom of the hi-hat so
on top what he's really just she's
playing like every other note the trip
was like dot dot dot dot dot dot that
but he gets it he's bringing that stick
up the one underneath hit fit so that's
how he gets the full sixteenth note
right sorry I know this is really nerdy
[ __ ] and then with his left hand he's
basically ghosting the offbeat and and
then playing the backbeat on two and
four and then dragon I believe on the
final note of the triplet into one
that's what he's doing now I know let's
drum nerd [ __ ] but I'll post the video
it's [ __ ] insane so of course I went
to the you know went down to the studio
the next day and I tried to do it you
know for like 10 minutes you know
according in whatever you learn
something you know the first thing you
do is you immediately try to play it
at the same tempo which is the drum God
that you saw playing it so it was really
[ __ ] frustrating I think I said what
the [ __ ] like 10 times and then I just
you know just scrolled through my iPod
iPad whatever my five phones and I hey
man and just had planted the same [ __ ]
I've been playing through for 30 [ __ ]
years I don't know what my dealing I
can't get out of it thank God I buy new
clothes you know a flat you should be
like you should be forced to wear the
clothes if you don't move ahead
artistically
your wardrobe shouldn't either you
should be forced to [ __ ] wear the
stage I should be wearing acid-washed
jeans with a [ __ ] half shirt driving
down the street my rusted-out 83 Ford
Ranger and they'd be like listen if
you're not going to progress with the
art of music you or whatever you can
watch the same ten [ __ ] films yeah I
had no idea how far behind I was so I'm
looking at mute math like they haven't
been [ __ ] crushing it for 10 years I
actually went on the internet I looked
them up and they like did let them in
2005 there you go built way to be on the
cutting edge so whatever I feel like I
took a major step forward but I want to
thank everyone in the band for you know
letting us come back and saying hello
real quick Darren Paul Roy and Todd you
guys will [ __ ] you crushed it and
thank you to Andrew for taking me down
there and pointing out what the [ __ ] was
going on so I could you know so the old
man could figure it out but I will
definitely see those guys whenever I'm
in a city that they're in a do it it was
that good of a [ __ ] show like I said
they're in Portland then Seattle and
they got a week off then they're in our
Richmond so definitely check it out
anyway plowing ahead here so that was my
Friday
all right towards the comedian there's
no way you take a Friday Saturday off
unless the UFC has a [ __ ]
pay-per-view and it's caught on my dad
and Holly Holm was fighting right so I'm
like alright I got to watch I thought
they were both title fights I didn't
realize that connor's fight was not a
title fight I think most people didn't
realize
most people like me got drawn into a
sport when there's someone like kids you
know I go in and out of the UFC you know
like most [ __ ] I go we're not a cooking
I go in and out of being a good comedian
I'm just I'm in and out right I'm a
[ __ ] Gemini I'm into it I'm into it
go [ __ ] yourself hey remember that [ __ ]
now I come back right except with my
music I just held onto it for a little
little patience you know is doing much
well what am I talking about anyway so
we have a bunch of people over right we
go out I go to the grocery store I get a
bunch I get the booze I get I get some
GABA woo I get some [ __ ] edgy Baiul I
get some [ __ ] cheese and all of that
[ __ ] all right I go on I get a bunch of
ice cream sandwiches after everybody's
all [ __ ] salt it up with the Doritos
and we sit down to watch the [ __ ] and
what a [ __ ] pay-per-view man you know
spoiler alert you know if you haven't
heard yet I'm going to say who won we
should take beat Holly home you know and
Nate Diaz beat Conor McGregor it was
[ __ ] unreal Mike but I'm anybody else
host a UFC fight party how [ __ ]
satisfied did you feel was unreal I had
like ten people screaming oh my god over
and over again like twice in one night
flipping the [ __ ] out more screaming and
yelling during that pay-per-view that
I've heard in any Super Bowl you know I
don't know a Super Bowl party that I've
been to in a while
it was unbelievable but Jesus Christ
once again
well I always hate what like when a
comedian is getting ready for a special
or a late-night spot and they say that
they trained like a fighter and it's so
disrespectful to what the men and women
do who fight for a [ __ ] living it is
it is the most badass I'm trying to
think of like a more badass job than
that other than you know you're one of
the grunts on the frontline in a war
then you [ __ ] job is you just
you're training to beat the [ __ ] out of
somebody who's training to beat the [ __ ]
out of you and you both are
professionals you'd do it for a living a
whole crowd of people shows up you ever
fight after school and like ten people
showed up was [ __ ] nerve-wracking
slide five fight guys walk into a
[ __ ] arena shirtless just walk it
down there and they got to stare down
some [ __ ] maniac a little no or the
dope on the ground right and it just
taking [ __ ] elbows and they have the
presence of mind to look over at the
clock like how much more than [ __ ] I
another minute thirty eight of forearms
to my [ __ ] forehead I don't know how
they take it so unbelievable fight I
didn't realize that Connor had gone up
into weight class it's like I said I'm a
very like novice fan of this stuff but
Jesus Christ
[ __ ] Nate Diaz sitting at his whole
face is all bloody and into that you
know I got this I've taken your worst
shots you can't knock me out that's just
scar tissue I've bled before I don't
know I don't know how to [ __ ] you do
that he was bleeding so much it looked
like both of them were bleeding to death
does he once he got up against McGregor
whether it was all over both of them I
don't know I really don't have anything
to say other than I was blown away by
both [ __ ] fights and you know as hard
as it is to what I was was to watch
Connor lose because I mean the guy's a
[ __ ] superstar talking [ __ ] and then
backing it up
it was FINA watching Nate to his choking
- [ __ ] it I was [ __ ] unreal I don't
know I don't know enough about the sport
to talk about it intelligently but I
will say this I hate when someone like
Connor loses and then everybody yeah you
[ __ ] [ __ ] say all that [ __ ] on the
internet you know go on Twitter and
start trashing the guy you know I want
to talk to people right now if you want
those people that dude how do you how do
you like how do you do something like
that and like look yourself in the
mirror when you go to brush your teeth
that night you know knowing you haven't
had a fight since like the seventh grade
you know the [ __ ] is wrong with you
you'll totally [ __ ] [ __ ] that's what I
made it great selling the fight I don't
know how great was that [ __ ] line you
just knocked out Connor mode choked out
Conor McGregor how does it feel he grabs
the mic goes I'm not surprised
[ __ ] I don't know about you
guys that's one of the [ __ ] coolest
things I've ever seen
the [ __ ] choked out someone is good
as McGregor the stand-up all [ __ ]
bloody and just walk around flexing not
even wiping the blood off not concerned
about how [ __ ] up your faces you don't
give a [ __ ] right whatever Jesus Christ
the second I got a little scratch I
would have just oh my god my sling god
that was going to see me Misha went to
but I fell Oh fair skinned person I felt
bad for Holly Holm you know just the
second we start getting beat on just the
compar face just gets so [ __ ] red and
then our yellow eyebrows stand out I
just thought there was a lot of mean
shifts that a butter when it came to
that I just really related to it by the
way what the [ __ ] happened in eights the
side of his face and his neck those
scratches on a nap look somebody took
like a [ __ ] nucleus like someone took
a nice down the side of his face in his
neck he's just sitting there pawn at it
I've gotten scratched like that every
time somebody like exhale just the wind
of that made me go into the fetal
position but anyways you know as great
as that UFC pay-per-view was it what
just makes me so [ __ ] sad about what
has happened to boxing if it just could
somehow if all the piece of [ __ ]
promoters in boxing could just unify and
become one piece of [ __ ] promoter you
know promotional entity like the UFC is
right because you know you know you know
the deal I don't know if you're if
you're if you're in any level of show
business
you know the promoters are [ __ ] over
the axe you know they are in UFC it's
the fighters you know I know and stuff I
don't know anything about it but I don't
sell of a pair they are getting [ __ ]
and because they're a complete monopoly
I'm sure they're [ __ ] with their
money I'm sure there's a pressure to
make people fight in that type of [ __ ]
which is why they try to break up
monopolies having said that it's [ __ ]
great for the fence because the fact
that the fighters have no other option
it's just the best fight the best and
like last night like I haven't had that
kind of excitement like watching like a
boxing pay-per-view like consistently
the way the UFC is consistently exciting
like that said I would say the
middleweight division in the early
eighties when you had Roberto Duran
Tommy Hearns Marvelous Marvin Hagler and
Sugar Ray Leonard all fighting each
other they all fought each other they
fought each other numerous [ __ ] times
it was incredible
I guess I'm Mike Tyson came along but
that was just more the spectacle of how
quick was he going to just knock these
people out I don't know just seen a
pay-per-view like that and then seeing
that it took [ __ ] ten years for the
Mayweather Pacquiao fight and then one
of them shows up and he's [ __ ] hurt
and doesn't say anything except he
doesn't say anything and you still out
sixty bucks it's just [ __ ] brutal so
anyways hats off to that [ __ ]
pay-per-view Jesus Christ actually watch
the McGregor fight again I'm [ __ ]
believable I was just looking at the
blood I'm going he's just going to keep
[ __ ] punching him right in that I
just keep punching him right in that
[ __ ] and I like who did that to that guy
with the [ __ ] yellow hair bleached
hair was it [ __ ] what the [ __ ] was
his name
GSP I came in his [ __ ] names you just
kept punching to do in the eye over and
over and over and there was always I
thought that that's what my Greg was
benders keep punching Nate in that
[ __ ] knife I just don't know how you
do it
how the [ __ ] you sit there with me I'm
done [ __ ] done he scratched me I am
done
keep fighting alright I just keep saying
the same thing over again I was blown
away by and respect to everybody who
fought there anyways you know it's way
too as McGregor is still the champion I
didn't know that I thought I just
assumed if you lost that's it right
you're not a champ anymore we're on the
belt
you're always a champ right how do I get
out of this I don't know anything about
this sport all right let me let me get
to the advertiser that always saves me
the [ __ ] is it
Oh God Thanks there it is Barry oh here
we go about us yadi me undies drying up
you [ __ ] [ __ ] but do me undies
biondi's is right don't say it it's not
Yanni's what are you wearing a suit or
sweats you spend almost 24 hours a day
and yeah underway but instead of making
a statement like Superman's tights under
his everyday clothes your underwear is
probably boring the undies is here to
change that they're going to give you
exciting underwear introducing male
panties please include the following
it's pronounced modal I don't know how
many times I have to mispronounce this
before I get some decent copy all right
it's all written in lowercase
MOH - da l it doesn't tell me which ones
to [ __ ] stretch it's either modal or
modal model I was like no accident is
that good every pair of my undies is
made from sustainable source modal no
doubt a fabric that's twice as soft as
cotton nothing can describe the fit and
feel of me undies are when they get up
against your balls a smile just comes
across your face like the grinch on
Christmas but once you try them on
you're going to understand while they're
called why they are called the world's
most comfortable underwear who calls
them that why me undies does then I call
the world they're called by you you came
up with that in the [ __ ] advertising
room
I think what Michael Jackson just called
himself the King of Pop I'm the King of
Pop how are you twinkle toes
what else are you you're a little teapot
and if you don't love your first pair of
me undies they're free no questions
asked me undies has dozens of styles and
limited edition prints to help you make
a statement with your underwear whether
you can see them anut remember remember
Superman some I think it was a joke in
there and I blew it
shipping is free in the US and Canada
and you could save up to $8 a pair of
the me undies within the undies
subscription can get planned get the
subscription or a single pair get 20%
off your first order when you go to me
undies comm / / we mean subscription
what do you have a new pair underwear
every month it's like Columbia Records
and tapes that me that's my undies comm
/ burn for 20% off your first order neo
nice calm / / oh here we go Dollar Shave
Club everybody you got a lot of stubble
on your face you are Harry broad do you
want to shave you [ __ ] there is its
birthday coming up and you want to be
all smooth well why don't you take out
dr. cavities easy shave blood and put it
on your pudding yeah you guys I figured
out I discovered the key to an amazing
shape evidently it's simple that's the
that's exactly what dollarshaveclub.com
does and why evidently I'm a proud
member like millions of others they
allege dollarshaveclub.com delivers
amazing razors right to my door for a
third of the price of what the greedy
razor corporations charge and they make
you go to the store those blue blooded
[ __ ] both my wallet and face finally
get some relief joining
dollarshaveclub.com means you can afford
to shave with a fresh blade anytime you
want which feels fantastic it's like new
money right you throw it in the
fireplace because you don't know any
better and for the smoothest shave ever
use your fresh Dollar Shave Club blade
with their doctor copies anything shea
butter it's not your average shave cream
every
this is high-quality ingredients that
make your skin feel soft smooth and
moisturize your blade will just glide
gently across your skin if you want the
most amazing shades possible take it
from me or don't take it from me take it
from your friends you know take a [ __ ]
do whatever you want to do use the fresh
dr. shave Dollar Shave Club blade with
dr. caddies ez shea butter two reasons
to join dollarshaveclub.com / burr today
that's dollarshaveclub.com / / high
dollarshaveclub.com / / and finally
lastly oh no I got two more alright so
I'll take a break here Jesus Christ we
got three more we got to get over the
hump here right MVM t watches movement
watches was started by Michael Victor
Michael tango you know that reminds me
is that that new Tina Fey movie
whiskey-tango-foxtrot
effective is that not the worst
advertised movie you've ever [ __ ]
seen it just is whiskey-tango-foxtrot
she's standing there squinting into the
Sun holding a notepad and there's
something on fire behind her that's it
that's all I get you know you can't hook
her up with a little [ __ ] to script
description oh maybe I'm old maybe that
maybe that's that's the way the kids
like it they don't want to know whether
it was a call of a slug line or some
[ __ ] I don't know I'm just right next to
another [ __ ] billboard and there's
like a like three Japanese looking dudes
holding shogun warrior swords and i know
what that's about
i know roughly where it takes place you
can't just squint into the sun home in
Notepad you know it's like is she in
Arizona is there RV on fire in the Grand
Canyon is she in Iraq maybe that's what
he's supposed to do like I'm supposed to
piqued my interest and I'm supposed to
go on the internet but if you're someone
like me who doesn't matter look up [ __ ]
you know or starts to look something up
and sees a picture of something else and
then clicks on that and then two hours
later goes wait a minute wasn't I going
to look something up and you can't
[ __ ] remember what it was I'm just
saying I think she's earned
I think she earned a you know a little
more respect than that right well she
hasn't made [ __ ] millions in box
office can you [ __ ] help her out with
maybe half a sentence alright MVM t
watches everybody movement watches was
started by two college dropouts with the
idea to make quality watches that don't
break the bank starting at just $95 and
sold online they cut out all the
[ __ ] retail markup supposedly
movement sent some watches over here
question mark yeah they did why don't I
just get this generic copy huh am I
going to go a little Kanye West right
now and have a [ __ ] is he said what
why can't why can't they [ __ ] you
know supposedly movement watch you sent
him over here yeah they did and I
already talked about it why would you
put that in the copy you're not going to
read it I'm like Ron Burgundy I'm Ron
Bert's be quality materials and sleek
design the perfect everyday watch is
easy order online today for free
shipping free returns in a 24 month
warranty that's pretty good huh $95
watch for the two-year warranty join the
movement and say no to big brand retail
markups and say saying yes to great
style check out MB and Delaney say no to
big brand retailer you can forward a
Rolex you wouldn't go [ __ ] do it of
course you would alright let's call a
spade a spade here you want to Rolex you
can't afford one but you don't have some
piece of [ __ ] this is it this is where
you're at in life but $95 [ __ ] watch
that's going to look like a $800 watch
okay we've all been there
goddammit go ahead beep empty [ __ ]
watches calm there's no [ __ ] in there
slash bar and you get 15% off your
entire purchase that's mbem T watches
dot-com / / alright Jesus Christ hey you
know what I did last night a trained
here in California it never rains in
California the boy don't be bored yeah
the pause man it pause sorry um I was
sleeping upstairs last night oh [ __ ]
Joey roses won by the house we had a
couple of cocktails right and then he
went home / dit like the hipster that he
is over to his hipster neighborhood you
know this [ __ ] is Jegs on whatever
the kids were wearing nowadays and I
don't buy the only time I snore is when
I [ __ ] booze so I wasn't going to do
that to the lovely Mia so I crashed
upstairs and it started thundering and
lightning at night and what's [ __ ]
hilarious about living out here /
terrifying is it never rains so when you
hear thunder you automatically think
it's a [ __ ] earthquake but your bed
isn't moving so you kind of like oh wait
a minute
am i I've never heard an earthquake that
I couldn't feel you got to like do the
math when you have a suite going like
that like an earthquake and you know in
the valley and I can't [ __ ] hear I
can hear it but I can't feel it that
that doesn't make any sense
and then you find figure oh my god
that's Thunder holy [ __ ] it's [ __ ]
raining out all right what is that in
front you put your plus I can't [ __ ]
remember stuck at that [ __ ] in edge it
is snowing
anyway so it starts [ __ ] raining and
it's tremendous it's rained a budget in
El Nino year
thank Christ and but what else always
was the depressing thing in the back of
my head is green and as lush as the
hills look right now this is like
basically the only rain we're going to
get for the next [ __ ] three years and
I know every [ __ ] out here is taking
long showers now going a the [ __ ]
droughts over you know I just hope and I
know I hope it [ __ ] rain keeps
raining as much as it possibly [ __ ]
can't or I can order them a massive god
damn plague out here one or the other
something's got to give right that's
depressing is it alright let's get into
oh no wait I was gonna tell you another
thing
so yesterday I was just driving around
hanging out with my wife and they get a
bunch of open houses out
so I can't [ __ ] it let's go look at some
houses you know get some ideas for our
old-ass kitchen see what a real kitchen
looks like right and I got to tell you
haven't bought this house and gone
through all this [ __ ] that I've gone
through I look at houses entirely
different immediately looking at the
windows do they have the old ass
original windows and I immediately want
to go downstairs if there's a crawlspace
anything I want to go down there and I'm
smelling for water and you can't really
do that a lot out here because then it
doesn't rain enough but I immediately
look underneath the [ __ ] house I look
right up it's [ __ ] skirt like the
home pervert I am and I'm immediately
looking for all right look see where did
the electrical work look look like you
know is a galvanized pipe what kind of
[ __ ] you know looking how stuff is
put together does this look like it had
a permit or not and you know all the
sexy [ __ ] goes away like we have a pool
and I'm just looking at it going like at
it says okay it looks like a piece of
[ __ ] to me that looks like you need to
redo the whole floor that [ __ ] thing
and if you got dumped out all the
[ __ ] water and evidently you can't
fill you pull up with water anymore out
here you have to fly the [ __ ] water
in so [ __ ] that pool I haven't got it in
the house yet you know well there's a
classic they're saying it's a two-car
garage but it is if you drive if you
drive to Model T Fords but if you have
any sort of modern car you're not going
to be able to get the all you can get to
in there but nobody can get out of the
cars so I was just a negative Nelly and
I actually realized that my house isn't
as bad as I thought it was now that I
[ __ ] dumped every [ __ ] dime that I
have into it now made me feel good I was
just walking the kitchen like there's no
prep space here all this disco [ __ ] I
don't see any place where I could
[ __ ] slice an English muffin you know
what [ __ ] this kitchen [ __ ] the pool
[ __ ] the kitchen and [ __ ] this
galvanized pipe oh oh look at this oh
wow rugs rugs in every run yeah take
your shoes off why is that yeah because
the floors haven't been refinished in
[ __ ] 80 years [ __ ] these floors let's
go upstairs oh great I see this used to
be an attic
oh yeah you call that an office yeah
yeah I like how you shown it during the
wintertime because I know what happens
in the summertime it [ __ ] heats up up
here right you can grow a [ __ ]
goddamn [ __ ] bushel of [ __ ]
marijuana up here I'd be [ __ ] three
hours
[ __ ] this office right you want to sign
up on our mailing list now I don't
because you're selling piece-of-shit
houses and then that that that I walked
I was done and of course I've set my
wife because all I did was just sorry I
actually only just shut off the [ __ ]
recorder
I actually I have to set my wife because
you know she's like I like you know
let's only they just have fun I
understand why you have to go in the
house and be rude to the real estate
people saying I don't like those people
you know because they don't encourage
you to sell your house you know
air-quote for a [ __ ] profit so then
you can buy back into the same market
and then everything you just made on
your house you got to buy you get to
spend again just to get the same [ __ ]
house I actually said that to the guy I
think that's that that's what made my
wife mad and I go yeah other people
making money out here are you in the
bank and the guys like well you know
that's not necessarily true
do the math tell me how that works can
we get you on the mailing list
alright let's read some [ __ ]
questions here questions here for the
goddamn week check this a cask is de Mol
something like what is what does I don't
[ __ ] about
descoteaux I'm just never going to get
you know why there's no reason for me to
speak it alright let's let's plow ahead
here alright um the March 3rd podcast
[ __ ] brilliant podcast yesterday
March March 3rd 2016 thank you
one of the very best and I've heard
hundreds of your podcast nobody drowns
in their own vomit anymore great brain
dude thank you Greg and amber let me
know if you're coming over here well
that's not a [ __ ] question that's
just a car you don't compliment this
question that's it
well thank you I'm going to be doing
Germany hopefully towards the end of the
year I'm definitely getting over there
all right
okay guy who invented the invented email
died he said uncle Freddie died uncle
Freddie hey Bill I'm sending you an
email about the guy who invented email
dying today
this is my way of honoring what he did I
imagine he'll get very little press
because nanstein just say no Reagan died
this weekend too here's an article from
an is an excerpt from an article about
him Internet Hall of Famer ray Tomlinson
has died Tomlinson was the man who
basically invented email as we know it
today including making the choice to use
the @ sign in an email address he was 74
years old
Tomlinson I think I said his name wrong
the first time
Tomlinson invented email a system where
a user on one network could send a
message to someone on the another
network in 1971
oh they left some of it out of there
Thomas been invented a network I mean
I'm going to read it the way I see it
Tomlinson or Thomason however I feel
like reading Tomlinson invented email a
system where a user on one network could
send a message to someone on another
network while the government advertisers
and hackers could all read your private
information this was invented in 1971
had Tomlinson had any idea what people
were going to do with his invention
would he have made it what do you have
invented it and the answer is of course
he would have how else was he going to
get some [ __ ] all right
this was his slugline hey can you meet
my [ __ ] friend Tomlinson over here I
don't want to meet him
he invented email oh my god hey you can
I touch your peepee that's actually
really interesting there's internet
hall-of-famers now I have to look that
up who's in the internet Hall of Fame
Jesus Christ I want to see images too I
wanna see what the [ __ ] these people
look like Internet Hall of Fame
here we go come on man
the internet Hall of Fame homepage holy
[ __ ]
2014 Hall of Fame inductees I didn't
know this this is [ __ ] awesome
Internet Hall of Fame Paul vixie
internet piracy well let me see the list
inductees all right here we go here's a
list is a list of who who is it all
right here's some of the pioneers look
at these [ __ ] eggheads Jesus Christ
Wow Wow
oh my god if I could do a [ __ ]
screenshot of this I got to put the link
up here my god what is it about being
super smart and just yeah I guess
everybody gets one gift
I'll tell these people this is a rough
one you know there's a lot of [ __ ]
lonely prom nights on this page all
right Douglas Engelbart and he's as
good-looking as that [ __ ] name he
looks like a sweet old man let's see
what this guy dougie Jesus Christ he's
got the old man faced in 1963 dr.
Engelbart founded the augmentation
Research Center lab at SR yes how do you
tell a woman that that's your dream and
she's not going to glaze over try doing
that while that [ __ ] I can feel my
faintly I'm with you I said I want to
start the augmentation Research Center
lab where you going where he pioneered a
system for augmenting human intellect in
which workers sitting at display
workstations could collaborate on
solutions to humanity's problems through
a vast online information space that did
it matter that no one ever [ __ ] uses
it look at this guy he [ __ ] does he
this is what all these guys are all all
these men and women their hearts in the
right [ __ ] place and then the [ __ ]
Luna
in these corporations these sociopaths
get their [ __ ] manicured fingers on
these things all right Susan Estrada you
could tell she was a looker back in the
day god I bet all these guys suck and
jerked off to her huh
she came around the [ __ ] augmentation
lab does in here yet yes it's probably
why she's probably the woman why there
she was this is this woman here was
probably the inspiration for the [ __ ]
virtual reality section but they're
trying to work on Estrada founded Cerf
surf net one of the original regional IP
networks in 1988 surf net serves the
academic and commercial communities in
California I still don't even know what
it is as an executive director she took
the initial National Science Foundation
funding 2.8 million dollars and grew the
network from 25 sites to hundreds of
sites I don't know what it does all
right let's split look at this with
Dennis Jennings this guy looks like a
[ __ ] NFL rest from 1958 as the first
program director for networking at the
US National Science Foundation dr.
Jennings was responsible for the design
and the development of NSFNET program no
way he did that I have no idea what his
[ __ ] people did come on man trying to
find somebody looks okay this guy is not
a bad looking guy oh yes he is he isn't
he's got a full head of hair but you can
just see he's a spaz you know he's one
of those guys seems sort of cool until
he starts laughing at the kids all right
Eric Deena Deena co-created with fellow
Internet Hall of Famer Mark Anderson the
first version of the mosaic web browser
in 1993 I think I kind of know what that
is all right you know what and with that
I'm [ __ ] bored just like the chicks
walking away from these people at the
BLA Internet Hall of Famer well you know
what moment of silence for ray Tomlinson
his heart was in the right place
who knew that pedophiles would use his
invent
to send pictures and [ __ ] alright from
Scotland dear Billy big dick I've had
been working flat out in work back in
Scotland and now taking a three-week
vacation in the US I'm 27 years old and
have never been across the pond so this
is a big deal for me well welcome a
chance to see you nutcases up close and
personal I'm planning Vegas death valley
and Grand Canyon to see some outdoor
epicness then on to Chicago to see the
Blackhawks wipe the floor with the
Flyers wow manners that's something a
great trip then Paddy's Day oh boy then
New York City to pop my wee cherry to a
first time in the US what would be your
top 3 things to do we really appreciate
the advice alas go [ __ ] yourself you big
nancy boy ok
the three things I would do well I mean
you're kind of doing you're doing some
amazing [ __ ] alright they say if I was
coming to America what would i do not do
I live here I don't know what the [ __ ]
to do that's like you know you never
know what the touristy [ __ ] is to do
when you're ten you're taking your own
place you take it for granted like when
I lived in New York I never went to this
I went to Statue of Liberty once I went
where my grandmother visited you know
I'm doing that [ __ ] I was just trying to
get to work alright if I had to pick
three cities I would do [ __ ] only three
all right you got to go to New York I
would say Chicago but you get enough New
York with Chicago I would see San
Francisco and then you'd have to do
something down south you know just to
get kind of you get both coasts and then
you get down south and all of those are
their own [ __ ] worlds what would I do
I don't want a Blackhawks game is
[ __ ] great dude you know what you
dumped me I don't know what I would do I
would go to New York like you're gonna
do and I would [ __ ] do as much [ __ ]
as I can you can't miss
there it was a nice vague answer [ __ ]
would you do I don't know I live here I
don't know what the [ __ ] would I do if I
went to Scotland go ahead give me give
me your mushy pea ideas I guess I would
I would go to I will go to a rugby game
I think you know something if you're
going somewhere you have way more ideas
than the person who's living there I
can't believe I can't think of anything
to do I you know what I go to a [ __ ]
steak house you know what I would
definitely indulge in the [ __ ]
cuisine over here there we go I'll get
my footing here all right you're going
to a hockey game I go to a sporting
event I need sort of [ __ ] basketball
anything you can see if you can go see
the [ __ ] Golden State Warriors they
one of the best regular-season records
of all times we can take in a [ __ ]
show go see a new mask for [ __ ] sakes I
don't know what I would do dude I'd go
down south right I go to a [ __ ] gun
range do something like that you want
this what you want to do you want to do
some Metropolitan [ __ ] you want to do
some sports [ __ ] and then you got to do
some back forward backwards [ __ ] that's
what I would do you know
don't find somebody drinking some
moonshine out of a [ __ ] jar a mason
jar and then you know have them [ __ ]
smoke a goddamned pork shoulder and go
out and shoot his guns there you go
right from 4-wheelers you know do
something like that I don't know you
know a lot of people sleep on like
Wyoming Montana the Dakotas those can
all be fun to go see I don't consider
you guys living that little ass country
you know I don't know dude I've ran a
[ __ ] classic American car and when I
went from [ __ ] New York to Chicago I
would drive that I wouldn't take the
highways I try to find some old route
and I'd stop off the greasy spoons there
you go there we go Jesus there's a
couple ideas I'm sorry I really [ __ ]
you over on that one but uh I don't know
that's like when somebody you remember
back in the day when you actually
shopped you bought CDs and stuff I sell
all these CDs I want to buy and then
when I would
walk into virgin I could never remember
what the [ __ ] I wanted I'm sorry man I
really dropped the ball on that one
all right to a first-timer in the other
that's not it Podcast got me in trouble
with fiance's family
hey there billary Burum Clinton I [ __ ]
up man as you can probably guess from
the subject line cue the og age as a
little background I'm getting married
next month to my fiance who was
wonderful love of my life and all that
we were visiting her family last night
and playing board games which we often
do
oh Jesus what happened when you drink it
did you get competitive huh J'Accuse her
mom of cheating goes I'll spare you the
details but we were playing a card game
with a bunch of characters everyone gets
the same people but when you use them is
really the key to the game there was a
particularly powerful card I had held on
to until the very last stage of the game
the character's name was granny wada
[Music]
pronounced gary wada i gave you the
pronunciation and accent so you wouldn't
[ __ ] it up well it is spelled w ATA
granny what now it's the last round of
the game and everyone's going around
revealing their card I was last and my
plan had worked perfectly as I went to
reveal it my inner billboard took over
and I really got excited I flipped it
over oh you did it he goes oh no oh no
he goes I said it's granny [ __ ] why
don't you drop the F bug oh my god I
wish I had podcast a t-shirts like send
one to you
no you did because silence followed as
it echoed through the house my fiance's
family were stunned
they're not super uptight people but
people just don't just don't throw [ __ ]
around during a board game you know from
there it only got worse my fiance is
listen to your part
test so she knows I was imitating you
she tried to stammer out an explanation
oh no she had to explain away your
behavior ah dude he goes but it didn't
really do anything I also tried to
apologize sheepishly then on top of that
that move gave me enough points to win
the game over everyone so I had to
awkwardly mark my score which made me
the winner while dude oh you get married
next month for the [ __ ] taste of this
is still going to be in their mouth he
goes we left almost immediately after
and of course I got yelled at all the
way home I knew I deserved it so I
didn't even put up much of a fight
that's your first good move in this
story Wow because my question is do I
try and go out of my way to remedy the
situation or do I just hope everyone
forgets about it and moves on we're
getting married in six weeks so it's not
like I can avoid them for very long it's
because I [ __ ] crush the impression -
thanks - go [ __ ] yourself sorry for the
Hillary Clinton reference in the opener
I think she's a [ __ ] - I don't think
she's a [ __ ] I just don't think she's an
honest person and I don't think just
because of the fact that we've never had
a woman president but that's reason
enough to elect someone is dishonest and
it's phony as her anyways though you
know what I would I would actually
without your wife I would just drive
over there and just say listen I got to
apologize I've listened to this podcast
I'm a big fan of the guy I was making a
joke and in the moment I didn't realize
that you guys didn't listen to the
podcast if you want and just kept queue
up a clip will you have it which might
be a bad thing to do be like just have
me like save something else dr. commies
easy shave butter but then you might be
[ __ ] if I don't say [ __ ] just say just
tell him you're really embarrassed or
whatever I think if you went over there
by yourself I think especially her dad
because I think that's the big one there
I think there's something extra when
it's you know it's always extra you know
when you're getting married like you
know if you're a guy you know the the
dad's going to be looking at you twice
as hard
in the mantra big always nice relaxed
you know and then the other way around
is if you know they have a son and you
bring the woman around like the mothers
going to be [ __ ] looking at her to
see if she's a [ __ ] you know an evil
little [ __ ] you know the dads going to
be looking at you like is this guy going
to be overbearing and slap my [ __ ]
daughter right or whatever you know to
me be a piece of [ __ ] right oh my god
you Wow you said it's granny [ __ ]
water
oh I do it if you film that oh my god
Jesus Christ
do it I got to give you I got it like
tip of the cap for you there man for
doing that holy [ __ ]
I'm getting uncomfortable just thinking
about that well can I'll apologize can I
apologize to you fiance for being a bad
[ __ ] a bad influence thing you know
what plate is to wha plan to see you
your your future in-laws dear future
in-laws hello I'm Bill burr I'm the one
who says granny deaf in what I say this
type of stuff I've been the bad
influence don't be mad at him I'm sure
he's a wonderful human being I'm sorry
he missed up he messed up your little
card game there yeah he's going to make
a great son-in-law you know why cuz he
used dr. cavies easy shameless don't
play that to them that's not gonna get
you anything
he listens to [ __ ] he must be a [ __ ]
they gonna have half a [ __ ] kid alright
not eating birthday cake huge fan of the
podcast is a 27 year old who works in a
stereotypical white-collar suburban
office I thoroughly enjoy listening to
you by your bi-weekly rants at my desk
wonderful man speaking of which I work
in the corporate offices of
sales and distribution company that has
about 50 employees but only about 15
people work in my specific office
location which means that about once
every [ __ ] month we gather in
the big conference room and do the
cliche awkward office happy birthday
song oh no with candles and cake routine
and all of that what I am by no mean
ok well I am by no means a health nut I
also try very hard to take care of my
body during the work day by eating
properly in drinking lots of water I've
also gotten really into bike racing over
the past years which has taught me a lot
about the importance of nutrition etc so
the thought of eating a giant piece of
chocolate cake at 2:30 in the afternoon
when my eyes are practically bleeding
from staring at a computer screen all
day would do nothing but make me feel
like absolute [ __ ] and I really have no
interest very smart this is why for the
past couple of years I politely turned
down every piece of birthday cake that
has been offered to me at these
affirmation ceremonies unfortunately I
am the only one of my co-workers most of
whom are women who has adopted this no
cake philosophy so every single time I
stick I stick out like a sore thumb
after I declined the piece that has
passed to me at which point I have to
deal with this wave of passive
aggression from these leis regarding my
decision to abstain from the sacred
ritual I also share a birthday with one
of my co-workers so I am spared some of
the awkwardness that goes along with
refusing cake on my own birthday but
still made out to be some kind of
monster
ok Jesus going on and on here well I
have no intention of succumbing to the
peer pressure brought forth by my
colleagues this might be the best
written [ __ ] letter I've ever had on
the podcast is it possible that I'm
being rude by not sharing in the
celebration what's more is that even if
I found out people did feel that I was
being douchey by not eating cake I still
wouldn't give a [ __ ] what they think but
this makes me a sociopath no it doesn't
it makes you somebody who knows what he
wants and everybody else is you know you
just you just get you know what you need
to just get a little space here couple a
little verbal
you know you know you know the great
ones create space and all you know
football hockey basketball you don't
have to do that baseball but you know
what I mean
the great ones create space okay so what
you have to do is you have to tap into
your greatness and you have to create
space okay and just say look people it's
not that I'm not happy that it's your
birthday I just don't want to become a
lard-ass
I mean I'm not being a dick here but you
know a lot of you I'm not going to say
who over the years your slacks just keep
getting bigger because you keep eating
all this [ __ ] cake
all right you blowing out your body and
I'm not going to be a part of it and a
part of me dies every time and watch you
guys eat this [ __ ] but if that's what
you want to do by all means go ahead and
do it but I'm not going to become a
[ __ ] cow like most of you guys are
you know I mean happy you should have
bells around your [ __ ] necks all
right make it worth it they'll never ask
you for cake again you probably get
invited you know that's what [ __ ] uh
that's what Sidney Crosby would do right
Mario Lemieux the great ones to create
space now dude you're not a sociopath
right you're doing the right thing you
know I don't know I don't know why women
like sweets so much you know I actually
I like sweet I'm just a big food basket
I actually like sweets but when I stay
away from them for a while if you really
abstain from [ __ ] desserts and
everything if you walk into a place that
has a bunch of crazy desserts it doesn't
even look like like edible for human
consumption you know I mean it looks I
always said it looks like clown food you
know I mean like a clown sneezed
especially if it's really like a lot of
like fruits and [ __ ] whipped cream
and all that [ __ ] just looks ridiculous
it's always crazy colors greens and
purples right you're doing the right
thing that's all I'm saying
you doing the right thing you know
hearing the bike racing you're working
out you know this is a deal - you've
actually got a chance of bagging bagging
one of those [ __ ] cake eating broads
in your section because they
they going to see like I happen I'm
probably just testing you the other half
are [ __ ] probably codependent [ __ ]
cake eaters and they feel guilty you
know and they know that after they eat
that then that sugar is going to be in
their veins and then they're going to go
back to their desk and they're going to
start eating a handful of [ __ ]
cheddar flavored goldfish just shoving
them down you know I bet if you walked
around your little section and you have
your cubicles and you looked at their
keyboards I bet they keyboards are
greasy huh
I bet there's crumbs in them you know
what I think you're going to get too
good to work there we think about that
that's what I got out of that [ __ ]
letter all right there's your podcast
for this week I want to thank everybody
for listening did I read only I didn't
do all the [ __ ] advertising god damn
it bill say running your [ __ ] mouth
what do I got next aisle trunk club
everybody trunk club alright don't waste
a second of the New Year and a crowded
mall with trunk club you can make 2016
your most stylish year yet and you never
have to go to the goddamn mall you don't
have to do any work yourself someone
else is going to do it for you you know
it's like you're rich and you have your
own [ __ ] stylist it's going to be a
game-changer you get a fresh start you
start the year off on the right foot in
the right pants the right jacket or the
right pant a Long's and mentos right
momentö is built over the right shirt
Jimmy
trunk club is here to handle your
wardrobe so you can focus on what
matters what matters not going out there
and getting yourself a slice of [ __ ]
puck please include all of the following
points trunk club takes the hassle man
out of shopping by finding the best
clothes for your style you're going to
look like a million bucks at trunk
club.com slash for all you do is actual
answer some simple questions about your
style your preferences size and your
assigned an expert stylist
alright then your stylist goes on just
picks from the best premium and they
send a trunk of that [ __ ] over to you
you keep what you like and send back
when you don't in a prepaid trunk they
take out all the [ __ ] middleman from
all the [ __ ] and yeah for some
reason the copy keeps going on and on
you get what goes on
where you go take advantage you go to
trunk club calm / / trunk club calm / /
trunk club calm / / oh by the way it's a
brand new year trunk club we'll send you
stuff for free right shipping free both
wait go there get some clothes sent to
your house you like it keep it you don't
set it back in the [ __ ] trunk can't
make it any easier than that alright
stamps calm do you like going to the
post office well have fun Paco because
everybody else is doing stamps calm
trips to the post office they're never
convenient so why not get postage right
from your desk with stamps calm stamps
calm even gives you special postage
discounts you can get it to post time if
you like that one meaning including okay
use using your own computer and printer
you can buy and print official US
postage for any letter or package then
just hand it to your mailman your
mailman or your mail lady or drop it in
the mailbox it's that easy
no wonder over 500,000 small businesses
are already using stamps calm I use
Famicom whenever I [ __ ] myself out
spending on my posters I'm a [ __ ] if I
can figure it out
so can you right now you can sign up to
stamps calm and use my last name Barbie
you are our for this special offer for
week trial plus $110 bonus offer that
includes postage at a digital scale
don't wait gift don't wait get started
with stamps calm today don't go to go to
stamps calm before you do anything else
click on the microphone to top the
homepage and type in Barbie URL that
stamps.com enter birth yeah yeah hey
this guy at work oh you know I'm trying
to listen the money music that one I
can't look him too she sounds like she
got roofied
and I nail a gangbanger and bag and I
know she's one of those people you have
to watch her doing the song because
she's so beautiful like alright I can
deal with this but it was just their
voice like you'd break up with the rover
the phone what
Riana yeah she called me up and be like
yeah we have to break up all right shut
up
don't judge me I'm an hour in I'm out of
jokes that's why so this guy works at
this [ __ ] office and he's got into
cycling and working out in nutrition and
that type of thing so there's like 15
people in a little area of the office so
he goes that means about at least once a
month he has to go down to the [ __ ]
cafeteria and sing happy birthday to
somebody and then they're passing around
birthday cake so he always says he
doesn't want the birthday cake and then
they're like [ __ ] girl you can cake you
got to eat it too or will feel guilty
and he's like I'm like some sociopath
but I don't give a [ __ ]
should I stick to my guns or should I
just have cake what's the month oh you
gotta fix your guns and you should tell
people that you're on a diet because
people are like oh that's great yeah you
know because I've been really trying to
lose weight too I mean obviously about
today and you know they don't say that
as they're about ready to eat a piece of
cake what do you mean you can't go into
a crack house to tell everybody that you
got sober the crackhead is gonna be like
oh that's great well I mean you can
still you're right but you can still say
no none for me I'm trying to watch my
weight that's when they come back now I
just have one piece then you go hey
Betty
ya know does I know I really can I've
been doing really well does last month
and I'm really you know I really feel
good and I'm just you know know that if
[ __ ] peer pressure office offices are
the worst for that type of [ __ ] when I
worked in the office here I was always
someone's birthday someone's always like
I made brownies over the weekend and I
just like can't happen in my house
anymore you guys eat them and it's it's
hard because everyone's just eating
you're sitting in a [ __ ] cubicle all
day your board is [ __ ] probably the
bending machine I should caution is it
true that the bit [ __ ] is being when
they're at the office what all [ __ ]
be eating while and the female [ __ ]
all be eatin white wife white breeches
being why [ __ ] be I don't know baby
environments are so hard to be on a diet
with because it's yeah it's like food
constantly because it's so [ __ ]
boring to sit there all day you just eat
eat eat so now they're now to the cake
all right one last quick one all right I
gotta speaking of that this patty cakes
me to take her ass to the gym so you
look good to me thank you but starting
today since I'm going to my reunion
starting today why can't you get in
shape for me I mean I'm yeah
why are you for fall don't try to like
the hijack and my health gold it's not
about you okay it's about me I had spent
in there for a second all right we did
how do I help help this guy help this
guy out
all right so we sort of backtracking
here in the podcast all right I'm going
to paraphrase this the podcast got me in
trouble this dudes getting married in
six weeks he's over is don't read it
just listen to me I heard you talking
about it oh did you say really loudly he
said I playing a card game he has to cut
the trump card that's going to [ __ ]
beat everybody and the name of it is
granny whatta waa d8 so when he plays it
eats the last guy he slammed it down and
nobody listens to the police pounds his
future in-laws do not listen to the
podcast and he just slammed it down and
he goes I gotta read it
he goes it's granny [ __ ] wad and it
was just silence followed as it echoed
through the house my fiance and family
were stunned this not super uptight
people but people just don't throw [ __ ]
around during a board game you know it
only got worse his fiancee Troy I
listened to the podcast and just yeah
and she yelled at on the hallway see
what you're doing to people we get them
in trouble with their future in-laws I
think you owe that young man an apology
I did apologize and I apologize I made
him a little [ __ ] audio thing that he
could played into his uh in-laws oh is
it filled with you saying [ __ ] over and
over again why I had no that's going to
help but I had to do it in a way that
they like you know so what a bad
influence
oh it's just a silly awkward moment it's
fine everyone will get over it it's okay
it's funny story though all right so
what are you doing at the gym today
back at Rice nods like that
which I'm not looking forward to women
always be doing the legs okay why
wouldn't it be doing their legs Oh for
[ __ ] sakes
Jesus you still do not leave glasses of
water on the floor I tell you this all
the [ __ ] time you're always leaving
glasses of water on the floor this is
what happened how many times will we do
you knock over a glass of water because
you put on the floor how many times are
you done tonight
are you done yes can you say sorry for
spilling the water in here I'm sorry for
still in your water but also now there's
no but there's no bus to the sorry
you're either sorry you're not I'm sorry
so the wall Wow that's the podcast
everybody well see on Thursday success
ssssss